[Music]
I'm hoping if you play this back it's in
celebration
I hope families are reunited I hope he
get it back and it's something like a
normal version of the planet has been
restored if there ever was such a thing
[Music]
universe now if you told me ten years
ago that we weren't alone let alone you
know to this extent I mean I wouldn't be
surprised but come on know the epic
forces of darkness and light that have
come into play and for better or worse
that's the reality Morgan's gonna have
to find a way to grow up in
[Music]
so I thought I'd probably better record
a little greeting in the case of an
untimely death on my part I mean not
that death at anytime is an untimely
this time-travel thing that we're gonna
try and pull off tomorrow it's got me an
expression my head about the
survivability of then again that's the
hero gig part of the journey is the end
what am I having trigger fun
everything's gonna work out exactly the
way it's supposed to
[Music]
ellaby 3000 hey everybody it's Charlie I
got a lot of requests to do a video for
the gwen stacy scene at the end of
Avengers endgame so I'll explain what
that means for her future in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's a very big
Easter egg there's also another big
easter egg for Gwen Stacy during
spider-man far from home so we'll break
it down we're doing a giveaway for the
spider-man far from home blu-ray all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your best
spider-man 3 theory on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
there hasn't been a new version of Gwen
Stacy in the live-action movies since
Andrew Garfield's amazing spider-man
movies when Emma Stone played the
character my name is Ben Stacy I'm a
senior at Midtown science and I'm also
had an intern - dr. Connors so I'll be
with you for the duration of your visit
we do have animated spider went in the
spider-man into the spider verse movies
but that's sort of a different universe
for now even though they did joke about
including live-action elements in those
movies they had a brief live-action
element during the opening montage with
the popsicle but they haven't quite got
that meta yet they said that they
thought about including Tobey Maguire
Andrew Garfield in those movies so they
ever do something like that it would be
the mother of all Easter Egg videos
there was a big gwen stacy easter egg
during spiderman far from home that you
guys all probably spotted in the theater
but it was basically them giving a
seminal gwen stacy comic book moment to
another character when spider-man's
fighting Mysterio's illusions midway
through the movie in that warehouse one
of the illusions Mysterio creates is up
him holding MJ over the edge of the
Eiffel Tower Peter had told Mysterio
about his plan to tell MJ about his
feelings after they climbed to the top
of the Eiffel Tower in Paris during
their class trip so that's why Mysterio
creates that illusion but he throws
illusion MJ off of the Eiffel Tower and
spider-man isn't fast enough to catch
her making it seem like she falls to her
death very big easter egg for the death
of Gwen Stacy in the comics after Green
Goblin throws her off the George
Washington Bridge in New York City also
side tangent fun Easter Egg for that
it's meant to be the George Washington
Bridge but in the actual comic book it's
drawn to look like the Brooklyn Bridge
because that looks more iconic than once
they got to the first Tobey Maguire
spider-man movie they actually did that
same a moment but with MJ in Green
Goblin throwing her
the Brooklyn Bridge this is why only
fools are heroes because you never know
when some lunatic will come along with
the sadistic choice the woman you love
[Music]
so it's a bit of an easter egg for an
easter egg in that moment but in the
Tobey Maguire version he's able to save
her whereas in the comic book version
his webbing when he tries a safer
accidentally gives her whiplash snapping
her neck and that's what the cause of
death is Roy Thomas the editor at the
time explained that the reason why
Marvel made it be that way is because
they wanted a no-win situation for
spider-man if he didn't save Gwen Stacy
then she would have fallen to her death
but because he did try to save her he
accidentally snapped her neck so Marvel
Comics was like we're killing Gwen Stacy
off no matter what happens but they did
do the actual comic book version of that
during Andrew Garfield's spider-man
movies because those were meant to be a
bit darker so she actually does die
during that fall the gwen stacy scene
that everyone's talking about at the end
of Avengers endgame is during that
montage when they're playing back the
message that Iron Man recorded before
the big time heist about his sort of
last will and testament his thoughts
about the future wanting to be really
hopeful you get all those reunion scenes
with the different Avengers going back
to their families or going back to their
homes the first scene is Hawkeye going
back to be with his family the second
scene when Spiderman goes back to
Midtown high as when this Gwen Stacy
moment happens some of you may spotted
this in the theater or may just seen
people talking about it recently but
when Peter walks back into Midtown high
looking like he can barely believe what
just happened like what a crazy field
trip I just went on with the Avengers
all the other students are rushing
around him as if nothing has changed
they did finally address it during that
funny Betty Brant scene at the beginning
of spider-man far from home during her
news broadcast when she talks about the
snap and the blip and they have that
funny scene in the gym with all the band
members getting blip back in the middle
of the basketball game but there's this
girl that grabs your eye here that's
walking through the crowd as spider-man
and Ned leads are having their reunion
made to look like a giant walking Gwen
Stacy Easter Egg clearly referencing the
character with her heavy pink backpack
stands out in the crowd in the spiderweb
prints skirt in platinum blonde Gwen
Stacy hairdo as Peter and nedley's are
going to hug each other she just walks
right by him like the camera even
lingers a little bit on it when they get
to spider-man far from home though
there's no subsequent mention of this
pink backpack Gwen Stacy character just
the MJ Mysterio Gwen Stacy Easter Egg
during the illusions fight so what is
the future of Gwen Stacy in the movies
right now we have animated spider-gwen
in spider-man into the spider-verse
she'll come back during the sequel to
that movie that they're making right now
but they're also developing a spin-off
solo movie for her but that's gonna be
animated it won't be live-action Gwen
Stacy that's the only Gwen Stacy movie
of any kind that I've heard Sony is
developing here's the thing though the
MCU spider-man films that we've been
seeing aren't really doing any kind of
love triangle business they're just
focusing on the MJ character so there
doesn't seem to be much of a rush to
make Gwen Stacy a big MCU character
right now you could speculate though
because Kevin Feige and Amy Pascal have
said their primary goal and coming up
with new spider-man stories is to do
things that have never been done before
with the characters that instead of
doing Gwen Stacy as say like the first
love interest the Peter Parker had in
the comics they wait till Peters in
college at Empire State University to
introduce the character which might be
where they take Tom hones spider-man if
he comes back for another trilogy after
spider-man three unless they do some
crazy time jump between spider-man far
from home in the beginning of spider-man
3 which I don't expect them to do I
think it's more likely that Sony's gonna
make a beeline for live-action
spider-gwen inside the Sony venom verse
so we're not talking about the MCU here
they've already supposedly started
developing the live-action spider-verse
TV shows spider Gwen would be perfect
for something like that I did a video
this past weekend about the crossover TV
shows that Sony is developing with Lord
and Miller from the animated
spider-verse movies they're using Sony's
Marvel characters to create a couple TV
shows in the only Marvel characters that
Sony has are the Spider Man comic book
characters so that's why I say
live-action spider-verse TV shows
because all the shows are eventually
supposed to crossover like the Netflix
Marvel characters in the air verse DC TV
shows but they haven't said which
character
are gonna get those TV shows yet so I'm
not gonna hold my breath for any big
Gwen Stacy character during spider-man 3
or anything but let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do
with a live-action gwen stacy in the
movies do you want to see a regular gwen
stacy pop up or do you want them to skip
that and just go straight to alternate
universe spider-gwen
even though the Marvel movies in the MCU
are going heavy multiverse during Marvel
phase 4 I'm not expecting spider-man 3
to be a full-blown multiverse story they
kind of already use that as a joke
during Mysterio's backstory for
spider-man far from home and yes even
though Mysterio was lying about being
from Spider UK's Earth in the multiverse
as Kevin Feige said it himself at the
Marvel Comic Con panel Mysterio was not
lying about the existence of the
multiverse we'll talk more about that
when we get into Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness cannot wait to see
them do a legit Marvel horror film and
see Scarlet Witch completely off the
chain leave all your video requests in
the comments below I'm working on a new
Eternals video there's a Marvel phase 4
d23 panel where they're gonna show off
some footage from the upcoming movies so
of course I'll do videos for that
Twitter also finally fixed my Twitter
account there's a link for that in the
description and on the home page of my
channel so if you don't follow me on
Twitter that's where you can find the
link to that account but congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
video Chris hate please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everybody click here torn about Dark
Avengers and the other secret Marvel
movies that we just found out about and
click here for my spider-man far from
home deleted scenes video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]